but ladies nothing wrong being
promiscuous don't ever let anybody make
you feel bad about that but ladies you
guys got to own being [__] because
sometimes you'll [__] shame yourselves
that's not gonna help the movement okay
like you ever have sex with a girl
you're like all right I gotta go she's
like why she's gonna leave I feel like a
[__] it's like yeah you are
and that's okay
but I don't want you to think I'm a [__]
no I knew but there's nothing wrong with
it remember you can't tell other people
not to let Jamie do it to yourself and
then it kills you when I see women
trashing promiscuous women how about
Rachel huh what a [__] what do you mean
well she [__] a new guy every weekend
so what what do you do and every other
girl goes well I get some dinners and
drinks on them you got to spend some
money first so well wait a minute you're
calling her a [__] and you're a
prostitute
isn't that way weirder she's banging
guys she likes for free you're like how
much Lobster can I get with this clam
isn't that way horrier I don't know what
do I know I'm a feminist but yeah